Доброго дня! Мене звати Дар’я.
Це фізика 9 класу.
Тема сьогоднішнього нашого заняття:
“Закон всесвітнього тяжіння”.
Дуже часто ми чуємо, як ім’я
Ньютона асоціюють із яблуком.
Насправді не дарма. Тому що свого
часу він задумався про неймовірну річ.
Він подумав?
А що, як причина, з якою
Місяць обертається навколо Землі
і не летить геть у космос, і причина з
якою всі тіла падають на поверхню Землі,
в тому числі яблуко – що як
вони мають однакову природу?
Викликані якоюсь однією силою?
Що це може бути за сила?
Коли Ньютон думав про це, перше,
що спало на його думку – це наступне.
За третім законом Ньютона ми знаємо,
що сила дії дорівнює силі протидії.
Всім нам відомо – якщо вдарити стіл,
то боляче буде нам.
Третій закон Ньютона ми спостерігаємо
і на взаємодії Земля-Місяць.
Тобто, ми знаємо, що насправді
не лише Земля тягне на себе Місяць,
але і Місяць тягне на себе Землю.
Причому, з такою самою силою, за модулем.
Це проявляється в припливах та відпливах.
Це ті явища, які якраз викликанні
притяганням Місяцем водної поверхні Землі.
Отже, подумав Ньютон.
Як таке може бути, що Місяць притягає
на себе Землю з такою самою силою?
Відповідно, якщо ми кажемо, що між яблуком
та Землею виникає сила тієї самої природи,
то це означає, що маленьке
яблуко, що висить на гілці,
тягне на себе Землю з такою
самою силою, так само за аналогією,
з якою Земля тягне на себе яблуко.
Але ж тоді виходить, що якщо
ми повісимо поряд сусіднє яблуко,
то чому вони не будуть притягатися?
Якщо маленьке крихітне
яблуко володіє достатньою силою
для того щоб тягти на себе Землю?
А для того, щоб перетягнути
сусіднє яблуко, не має такої сили?
Тоді Ньютон зрозумів, що, напевно тому,
що сила притягання між об’єктами
залежить не від маси якогось одного з них,
а від маси обох. А саме від їхнього
добутку. Тобто від добутку m1 на m2.
Маса одного тіла на масу другого.
Що це пояснює?
Це пояснює, що якщо ми
розглядаємо взаємодію яблуко-Земля,
то маса Землі настільки велика,
що весь цей добуток буде числом
великим і сила буде відчутною.
Втім, якщо ми будемо вимірювати
силу притягання між двома яблуками
з крихітними масами,
то і сила буде незначна.
Тому ми і не спостерігаємо
їхнього притягання один до одного.
Інший висновок, до якого дійшов Ньютон.
Уявімо, що ми взяли одне з цих
яблук, та летимо геть у космос.
Вилітаємо в простори космосу.
Зупиняємо двигуни, або, принаймні,
починаємо рухатись рівномірно зі
сталою швидкістю. Відпустимо зараз яблуко.
Воно не впаде.
Так саме, насправді, як і ви в цей
момент не будете торкатися підлоги.
Справа в тому, що ви відлетіли
настільки далеко від поверхні Землі,
що її гравітаційне тяжіння вже на вас
не діє, або насправді діє, але дуже мало.
Відповідно Ньютон зробив висновок,
що сила взаємного притягання
між тілами падає із відстанню.
Отже, тому відстань я напишу в знаменнику,
бо із збільшенням цієї
величини – ця має падати.
Втім спостереження за планетами,
їхніми орбітами та швидкостями показали,
що, насправді, сила падає не просто
з відстанню, а з квадратом відстані.
Що це означає? Це значить, що якщо ми
підсунемо Місяць вдвічі ближче до Землі,
тобто зменшимо відстань між
Землею та Місяцем в два рази,
то сила зросте в чотири, в два в квадраті.
Власне, це та залежність,
яку зміг вивести Ньютон.
Втім, це все ще не повна формула.
По-перше, давайте подивимось на
одиниці вимірювання, які в нас вийшли.
Ми знаємо, що маса
вимірюється в кілограмах.
Отже, маса на масу – це буде кілограм в
квадраті. Відстань вимірюється в метрах.
Відстань в квадраті буде метри в квадраті.
Ми знаємо, що сила вимірюється в Ньютонах.
Один Ньютон дорівнює кілограм
на метр на секунду в квадраті.
Тобто одиниця вимірювання маси
на одиницю вимірювання прискорення.
Бачимо, що ці одиниці вимірювання
не дорівнюють одна одній.
Значить все ще ми поки що
не маємо справу з Ньютонами.
Це якась інша величина, але
не Ньютони, це ще не сила.
Дійсно, як що ми,
користуючись цією формулою,
спробуємо виміряти, наприклад,
силу притягання між двома людьми,
масами по 60 кілограмів, поставимо їх
на відстань один метр один від одного,
то отримаємо число 3600. Так, 60 на 60.
Це, насправді, дуже велике число.
Це сила в 6 разів більша, ніж та, з
якою мене зараз притягує до Землі.
А я дуже добре відчуваю,
як мене притягує до Землі.
Отже, формула ще не завершена.
Має бути якийсь множник,
його назвали гравітаційна стала, який буде
множитись відповідно на ось цей вираз.
Що це за множник, Ньютон не знав.
Свого часу виміряти гравітаційну сталу
вдалося британському
фізику Генрі Кавендішу.
Це був його видатний
експеримент з крутильними вагами.
Насправді, цей дослід настільки тонкий,
що вражає. Уявіть собі – що він зробив.
Це була ось така установка, на жердинці,
як ви бачите, є в нас дві кульки.
Це дві свинцеві кульки,
вони були не дуже важкі.
Вони знаходились
відповідно у стані рівноваги.
Тобто ця жердинка, вона не оберталася,
тому що ми нитку провели рівно
через центр цієї жердинки, маси однакові.
Отже, жердинка не
рухається, не обертається.
Поряд поставив свинцеві кульки.
Ось ці великі, в яких маса
вже була набагато більшою.
Згідно із законом всесвітнього тяжіння,
який каже, що будь які дві маси
притягуються одна до одної з силою F,
ці кульки мали б притягатися
і дійсно таке сталося.
Тобто маленькі свинцеві
кульки почали тяжіти до великих.
Звичайно ви розумієте, що це
настільки крихітні маси в масштабах Землі,
в масштабах планети, що виміряти – на
скільки вони притягаються одна до одної,
було надзвичайно важко.
Виведення сили, з якою
вони притягуються, іде від того,
на який кут відхилилась жердинка.
Або інакше кажучи – на скільки
закрутилась нитка при цьому відхиленні
і це надзвичайно важко. Сила,
яку вдалося виміряти таким чином
– вона дорівнювала вазі піщинки.
Настільки це був тонкий дослід.
Але Кавендішу це вдалося.
Тобто в його досліді, ще раз:
він мав, він знав маси своїх кульок,
отже у нього були m1 та m2.
Він знав на яку відстань, на яку він їх
поставив одна від одної, тобто він знав r.
Він виміряв за допомогою ось
цього кута, за допомогою обертання,
деформації нитки, він виміряв
силу з якою вони притягуються,
хоча це було надзвичайно маленьке число.
Таким чином, він знайшов ось
цей множник, який шукав Ньютон.
Він знайшов гравітаційну сталу.
Як ви можете бачити,
ця стала, яку він знайшов,
дорівнює 6,67 помножити на
10 в мінус одинадцятому степені.
Це надзвичайно маленьке
число – 10 мінус в одинадцятій.
Відповідно це дає нам відповіді на багато
питань якими ми задавались на початку.
Через те, що це надзвичайно
маленьке число,
то якщо ми візьмемо цей добуток,
що ми мали тут:
добуток мас двох людей
по 60 кілограмів кожна,
то при множенні на це маленьке число,
ми робимо силу надзвичайно маленькою.
Відповідно вона і не відчутна, але вона є.
І лише коли ми говоримо про великі маси
або хоча б одне з тіл
має достатньо велику масу
для того, щоб воно не зменшилось при
множенні на це надзвичайно маленьке число,
тільки тоді ця сила стає відчутною. Отже,
так виглядає закон всесвітнього тяжіння.
Революційною свого часу він був тому,
що Ньютон вивів, що будь які два
тіла притягуються один до одного.
Наприклад, я та цей стілець,
учень та парта, будь що.
Просто якщо ми маємо справу з
маленькими масами, то сила буде незначною.
Отже, тепер ми знаємо як
виглядає закон всесвітнього тяжіння,
який встановлює силу притягання
між двома тілами масою m1 та m2,
що розташовані на
відстані r одне від одного.
Давайте порахуємо – з якою силою тоді
буде притягати нас Земля за цією формулою.
Якщо ми хочемо дізнатися це,
а ця сила, напевно, ви знаєте
- називається сила тяжіння.
Тобто сила тяжіння - це сила,
з якою тіла притягуються до поверхні
Землі або іншого астрономічного тіла.
Отже, сила тяжіння в такому
випадку буде дорівнювати G,
замість однієї з маси я візьму масу нашого
тіла – чи то людина, чи будь що інше.
Друга маса, так як це взаємодія
між людиною та будь-яким тілом,
та Землею, друга маса буде масою Землі.
А далі, що ми маємо
писати на місці відстані?
Що як це тіло знаходиться
прямо на поверхні?
Ми ж не можемо написати
нуль, і дійсно - це не нуль.
Дуже важливо знати, що
точка прикладання цієї сили
гравітаційного тяжіння знаходиться
в центрі тяжіння. Що це значить?
Якщо ми намалюємо Землю
та уявімо, що зараз ми починаємо
подорож до центру Землі в її глибини.
Що ми будемо відчувати з
точки зору гравітаційного тяжіння?
Отже, починаємо подорож. Уявімо,
що зараз ми знаходимось в цій точці.
З одного боку позаду нас лишився
шар Землі який тягне нас на себе.
Отже, він так само має масу.
З другого боку є ще шар попереду,
який так само буде тягти нас на себе.
В який момент це тяжіння між тим, що
позаду нас і тим, що ще лишилося попереду,
коли воно буде врівноважене? Звичайно,
що коли тіло буде знаходитися в центрі,
коли ми досягнемо центру.
Саме тому кажуть, що центр тяжіння Землі
знаходиться в геометричному центрі кулі.
Ще раз, центр тяжіння - це
точка, в якій всі сили тяжіння,
що діють з боку інших
частин тіла, врівноважені.
Або, якщо так важко, інакше
кажучи, центр тяжіння – це та точка,
в якій необхідно підперти тіло,
щоб воно зберігало стан рівноваги.
Отже, силу тяжіння ми завжди
маємо відраховувати від центру тяжіння.
Так як для Землі це ось ця точка,
це її геометричний центр,
то рахувати тяжіння між нами
та Землею ми будемо від неї.
До речі, (це буде радіус) саме тому
всі планети мають таку сферичну форму,
тому що будь-яка частинка Землі
- вона тяжіє до центру тяжіння.
Центр тяжіння Землі
знаходиться в її центрі.
Відповідно кожна частинка Землі, кожна
точка поверхні – вона тяжіє до центру.
Тому ми і маємо таку кулясту форму,
яку мають всі планети, супутники, Сонце,
які володіють достатньою гравітацією
для того, щоб себе стиснути до кульки.
Отож, коли ми вимірюємо
тяжіння між нами та Землею,
ми маємо писати тут
радіус Землі в квадраті.
Це формула для знаходження сили тяжіння,
яку ми вивели
із всесвітнього закону тяжіння.
Тобто ще раз: всесвітній закон тяжіння
– це універсальна формула для
знаходження сили притягання
між будь-якими двома масами.
А це її окремий випадок.
Це сила притягання між будь якою масою на
поверхні Землі або поблизу неї та Землею.
Так само ми знаємо і іншу формулу
сили тяжіння.
З другого закону Ньютона нам
відомо, що коли на тіло діє певна сила,
то тіло в нас рухається рівноприскорено.
Якщо ця сила не змінюється,
постійно діє на нього,
то рух буде рівноприскорений
із прискоренням «a».
Ми знаємо, що коли
ми якесь тіло відпустимо
і воно буде падати на поверхню Землі,
тобто буде рухатись під дією сили тяжіння,
то тіло буде набирати
швидкість із прискоренням g.
Це є константа - g -
прискорення вільного падіння.
Тобто це те прискорення, з яким
падають всі тіла під дією сили тяжіння,
що приблизно дорівнює 9,8 метрів
на секунду в квадраті.
Таким чином, ми можемо з другого закону
Ньютона силу тяжіння так само розписати:
як маса нашого тіла
помножене на прискорення,
викликане цією силою, тобто на g.
Отож маємо дві формули для
вираження сили тяжіння, тобто сили,
з якою Земля притягує до себе предмети, що
розташовані на поверхні або поблизу неї.
Так як вони виражають одну і ту саму
величину ми можемо їх прирівняти.
Отож прирівняємо їх.
І отримаємо що: G –маса тіла на масу
Землі на радіус в квадраті дорівнює:
маса тіла на прискорення вільного падіння.
Бачимо, що дуже добре
скорочується маса нашого тіла.
Лишається наступна формула:
прискорення вільного падіння дорівнює:
гравітаційна стала, маса Землі,
радіус Землі в квадраті.
Це формула для знаходження
прискорення вільного падіння.
Давайте проаналізуємо її. По-перше,
ми бачимо, що маса нашого тіла зникла.
Це означає, що прискорення, з
яким падає тіло на поверхню Землі,
воно не залежить від маси цього тіла.
Це означає, що як
пір’їнка, так і важкий м’яч
– вони будуть падати
з однаковим прискоренням,
набирати однакову швидкість
за однаковий проміжок часу.
Далі ми бачимо, що прискорення
вільного падіння залежить від відстані.
Адже якщо ми, наприклад,
будемо із поверхні Землі рухатися
все далі-далі в космос, тобто до нашого
радіусу буде додаватись ще якась висота,
то ми будемо збільшувати ось цю величину.
А якщо ця величина збільшується,
то прискорення вільного
падіння відповідно зменшується.
А саме, якщо ми хочемо виміряти
прискорення вільного падіння
десь на висоті Н від поверхні Землі,
то форма відповідно буде
мати наступний вигляд:
G помножена на масу Землі,
і тут ми вже напишемо
радіус Землі плюс висота Н в квадраті.
Бачимо це також на слайді.
За допомогою цієї формули так само
можна знайти прискорення вільного падіння
на будь-якому тілі.
Для цього необхідно лише підставити
масу цього тіла, я маю на увазі, звичайно,
такі тіла, як Місяць, Меркурій, Венера,
Марс, будь яке астрономічне тіло,
на якому тіла будуть падати з
певним прискоренням на поверхню.
Якщо ми сюди підставимо
масу Місяця та радіус Місяця,
то зможемо знайти прискорення
вільного падіння на Місяці.
Це було підраховано і результати показали,
що прискорення вільного падіння
десь приблизно в шість разів
менше ніж на Землі.
Це десь 1,6 метрів на секунду в квадраті.
Отже, формула дійсно є корисною,
адже за допомогою неї ми можемо знайти
прискорення вільного падіння
на будь-якому астрономічному тілі.
Що важливо: в прискоренні вільного
падіння – воно не всюди однакове.
Тому я тут поставила знак
"приблизно дорівнює",
тому що насправді наша Земля
це не рівна кулька.
Через те, що Земля обертається,
то її екваторіальний радіус
– він трошки більший
на 21 кілометр за полярний.
Тому відстань від центра
тяжіння до поверхні на екваторі
буде більшою за цю відстань,
за відстань від центру до полюсу.
Тому і прискорення
вільного падіння на екваторі
трішки менше за прискорення
вільного падіння на полюсі.
Можна сказати, що на
екваторі тіла падають повільніше.
Таким чином, ми прийшли до
формули прискорення вільного падіння.
Через те, що при обчисленні гравітаційного
тяжіння між будь-якими двома тілами
нам необхідно шукати в них цей центр
тяжіння, про який ми з вами вже говорили,
то кажуть, що цей закон – він має
певні обмеження. Що це означає?
Уявіть собі, що я хочу виміряти
гравітаційне тяжіння між мною та
якоюсь горою, що розташована поблизу.
Отже є я і є гора,
умовно. Питання наступне.
Звідки мені починати обчислювати
відстань між нами, між мною та горою?
Ми вже з вами з’ясували, що
для того, щоб знайти цю точку,
з якої треба починати
відлічувати, як би ставити лінійку
– треба знайти центр тяжіння цього тіла.
Ми з вами знаємо, що
центр тяжіння – це точка,
в якій врівноважені сили
тяжіння між всіма частинками тіла.
Інакше кажучи, це точка, в
якій необхідно підперти тіло,
щоб воно зберігало стан рівноваги.
Як підперти гору, щоб вона
зберігала стан рівноваги?
Уявіть, вам необхідно поставити її на
якийсь вістряк так, щоб вона стояла,
зберігаючи стан спокою.
Отже, в такому випадку знайти цю
точку – центр тяжіння в горі важко.
Тому кажуть, що закон всесвітнього тяжіння
має певні обмеження до застосувань.
Тобто він буде працювати та
вимірювати найбільш точну силу притягання
між тілами лише в таких випадках.
По-перше, якщо розміри тіл нехтовно
малі порівняно з відстанню між ними,
тобто коли ми можемо прийняти
тіла за матеріальні точки без розмірів.
Це означає, що ми таки можемо
виміряти наше гравітаційне тяжіння
між горою та нами, але якщо ця гора
буде дуже далеко, на іншому кінці кулі,
щоб ми могли знехтувати її розмірами
і нам не потрібно було шукати в ній
центр тяжіння, цю точку. Це перше.
Друге. Якщо обидва тіла - однорідні
кулі. Про що мова? Ми вже з вами знаємо,
якщо ми маємо справу з кулями,
то центр тяжіння в них знаходиться
в геометричному центрі кулі.
Тому тут нам так само
легко знайти центр тяжіння.
З кулями закон всесвітнього тяжіння
– ця формула працює дуже добре.
І третій випадок. Якщо одне з тіл –
куля, розміри та маса якої значно більші,
ніж розміри та маси другого тіла, яке
перебуває на поверхні або поблизу неї.
Це приклад з нами та Землею.
Отже, якщо ми розглядаємо силу
гравітаційного тяжіння між нами та Землею,
то нашими розмірами так само в
цих масштабах можна знехтувати.
Отже, не треба шукати центр
тяжіння в нас або в тієї гори,
що знаходиться на поверхні.
Нам достатньо взяти радіус Землі
і це і буде відстань між
нашими центрами тяжіння.
Таким чином, це
обмеження, які встановлюють
– в якому випадку ця формула
працює найбільш точно.
Задача.
Увага на екран.
Тобто ми маємо Землю з її радіусом R.
Маємо якусь певну висоту,
нехай це буде висота h.
Знаємо, що на поверхні Землі
прискорення вільного падіння g,
а на висоті h від Землі
якесь певне g штрих.
Нам сказали, що за умовою, g
відноситься до g штрих як 9.
Тобто g в дев’ять разів
більше ніж g штрих:
прискорення вільного падіння на
поверхні в дев’ять разів більше за
те саме прискорення
на висоті h від поверхні.
Необхідно знайти, власне, цю висоту,
на якій стільки разів падає
прискорення вільного падіння.
Отже, давайте згадаємо формулу
прискорення вільного падіння,
яку ми з вами виводили вже.
Ми знайшли, що g – це гравітаційна стала,
помножити на масу Землі і
поділити на квадрат радіусу Землі.
Це прискорення вільного падіння
на поверхні, адже ми взяли радіус,
g штрих, відповідно буде дорівнювати:
гравітаційна стала, так само маса Землі,
але замість відстані ми вже візьмемо
– суму радіус Землі плюс висота
від поверхні в квадраті.
За умовою, якщо ми поділимо
перший вираз на другий, ми отримаємо 9.
Тож зробимо це. Поділимо g на g штрих.
Тоді ми отримаємо GM на R в квадраті.
Далі поділити на дріб означає
помножити на перевернутий.
Отже, ми напишемо множення
і перевертаємо цей дріб.
Тепер R плюс h в квадраті буде
в чисельнику, а в знаменнику GM.
Як ми можемо бачити,
ці значення скорочуються і
лишається лише R плюс h в квадраті
поділити на R в квадраті. Ми знаємо,
що це співвідношення дорівнює 9.
Можна записати далі, що R плюс
h поділити на R і все це в квадраті.
Якщо і чисельник, і знаменник в квадраті,
то ми можемо записати його під
спільним квадратом, дорівнює 9.
Для того, щоб дібратися
до відповіді, до цієї висоти,
ми можем зараз взяти під
корінь і лівий, і правий вираз.
Тоді ми отримаємо R плюс
H поділити на R дорівнює 3.
Наголошую на тому, що
мінус 3 в квадраті теж дає 9.
Але у нас мова йде про відстані,
які лише додатні. Тому беремо 3.
Звідси R плюс h дорівнює 3R. І
отримаємо, що висота дорівнює 2R землі.
Отже, коли тіло буде на висоті, що
дорівнює приблизно діаметру Землі
від поверхні, то прискорення вільного
падіння, а відповідно і сила тяжіння,
сила гравітаційного притягання між цими
об’єктами: між Землею та цим об’єктом,
вона зменшиться в 9 разів.
Радіус Землі – це приблизно
округлюючи буде 6400 кілометрів.
Тоді висота, яку нам необхідно було
знайти – це 6400 км помножити на 2,
дорівнює 12800 кілометрів. Це
і буде відповідь на нашу задачу.
Таким чином, за сьогодні ми зрозуміли:
що таке закон всесвітнього тяжіння;
чому будь-які тіла у Всесвіті притягуються
один до одного, але помітно це лише,
коли мова іде про великі маси;
вивели від чого залежать прискорення
вільного падіння на
поверхні Землі та поблизу неї.
На цьому все. Сподіваюсь, що вам було
цікаво та доступно і до нових зустрічей!